so we've all struggled with typeface
weights and fonts and alignments in our
design so what I want to talk to you
about today is how to easily apply a
couple different tricks and rules to get
your typefaces to really sit nicely
together that's what we're talking about
on today's video podcast
[Music]
hey there and welcome to the motion
science video podcast my name is Cameron
and I am glad to have you here today
we're gonna go over a couple quick tips
and tricks and rules essentially for
type to make it sit nicely together so
what we've got here is a isn't just a
very simple graphic design inside of
After Effects some layers some nice
shapes and colors and what we're going
to do is let's just pretend that this is
for the Rock and Roll Hall of Fame and
this is like a title card or something
like that for some type of video
presentation okay so what we need to
explain is that this is the Rock and
Roll Hall of Fame and there's a little
bit of description about what the Rock
and Roll Hall of Fame is okay and so
we're gonna do is we're gonna start with
rock let's actually go upper lower case
rock and roll and we're going to also
create another chunk of test text Hall
of Fame and we've got one more chunk of
text which I already have in here and
this is just copied and pasted from
Wikipedia about what the Rock and Roll
Hall of Fame is so if someone's coming
or let's say they're an event and this
is just a videos popping up saying like
welcome to Rock and Roll Hall of Fame
here's what it is right maybe it's an
experience or something it doesn't
matter but I just want to show you how
you can get this text to look good
because if we have all this text here
you know there's a huge chunk of text
there there's this is important and this
is important you know it's it's always
kind of a challenge for a lot of us to
kind of figure out okay well what's the
best way to arrange this how should I
make it not like that but how should I
make this look good well here's a simple
simple rule for you so the first we're
gonna do is we're gonna change all this
text to just a more interesting looking
typeface and we'll go próxima Nova okay
so that's just it's a nice looking
typeface we'll start with that we're
gonna make this an even number so we'll
make this its 87 let's make it a
typeface size of 100 and we're going to
make sure this is left aligned left
aligned
and left online okay great so they're
all left aligned now we could do center
alignment things like that but I just
want to show you using a left or right
justification is an easy way to get text
to look good together so looks like a
screen shot this is what it looks like
now and a simple rule is whatever our
second layer of type is we can do is we
can do two things the first thing that
we can do is since this is a hundred you
can see right here it's a hundred let's
make this half that size let's make it
fifty that's the first thing we're gonna
do we're making it a fifty okay
the next thing we're gonna do is we
started with bold so typically in type
if you go down to two weights below
where you currently are that's a good
rule to make your type look good
together so because we're at bold and
I'm not going to include italics okay
because we're at Boalt if we go to
weights down that'd be semi bold is one
and medium is two we're skipping italic
so if we're starting with bold we're
going down one to two medium okay
so we've got just a little bit lighter
weight to our typeface now okay so
that's the first rule or that's the
second rule sorry the first rule is
we're going to decrease the size by
about half so the first Rock and Roll
Hall of Fame rock and roll is a hundred
for a font size Hall of Fame is fifty
and then the second rule is rock and
roll is set to bold Hall of Fame has
dropped two weights to medium next thing
we're going to do is we're going to
bring this over here kind of line it
we're gonna do the same thing we're
gonna drop it since this Hall of Fame
was fifty we're gonna go half that size
to 25 and we're also going to drop it to
weights and Hall of Fame was set to
medium we're gonna go one two two light
okay and all the way through now is just
decrease our letting that something
looks nice
maybe something in there
and I'm just looking at the spacing here
between all these three chunks of text
and doing something like that and maybe
use my arrow key or just to align things
just a little bit better something like
that and there we go
look how nice that looks so we'll look
at where we were originally this which
is a lot in your face it's it's a lot of
information to this and this tells me
I'm going to go from an order of rock
and roll which is our most our heaviest
font our largest font to a middle font
weight and a middle font size to a small
font weight and a small font size and
this is called hierarchy in laying out
type and it works for really well so
that is how you can take any type in a
motion design piece or graphic design
piece and lay it out in a visually
interesting way that tells me where I
should have focused my attention one
after the other after the other that's
what I got for you on today's video
podcasts hope you learn something new
until next time my name is Cameron and
this is motion science see ya
[Music]